en contre mikhaïl gorbatchev jean paul
ii ce matin
cory aquino a repris le dessus aux
philippines
elle a maté la rébellion les états unis
s'étaient tout de suite porté à son
secours
maltais capitales du monde pour deux
jours dès le 1er sommes des bougeoirs
bat chef pour un nouvel équilibre
mondial
dix hommes 10 pays à travers
l'antarctique par le pôle sud
la lente progression de la transe
antartica avec le docteur jean louis
etienne
bonsoir l'histoire sous nos yeux
l'histoire en train de se faire avec une
page étonnante ce matin le numéro un
soviétique face au pap
gorbatchev face à jean paul de la
réunion a tenu ses promesses puisqu'elle
s'est conclue sur l' annonce de
relations diplomatiques noué entre
l'urss et le vatican et aussi l'annoncé
d'un probable voyage du pape en union
soviétique
nous allons revenir sur ses décisions
importantes mais d'abord l'événement
mais d'abord l'image l'héritier de
marque reçu au saint siège par
l'héritier de jésus jean marc il use
les chemins de la pérestroïka menée
aujourd'hui à rome et en franchissant ce
matin en cortège blindés les frontières
du vatican michail gorbatchev a voulu
mettre un terme à 72 ans d'hostilité
entre matérialisme athée et près de 2000
ans de foi chrétienne
ici le maître du kremlin encadré par une
escorte de gardes suisses se dirige vers
la bibliothèque privée du pape
mais une fois n'est pas coutume le chef
de l'église de rome viendra lui-même à
la rencontre du président soviétique
la réconciliation est celle là et puis
75 minutes de tête à tête sans
interprète jean paul ii parle aussi le
russe union premiers résultats d'une
rencontre historique soigneusement
préparé l'annnonce de l'instauration
prochaine de relations diplomatiques
entre le vatican allure et l'urss mais
le problème du statut des 5 millions de
chrétiens uniates ils veulent être
attaché à l'église de rome reste une
pierre d'achoppement
ce n'est que dans six mois que le
parlement soviétique se prononcera sur
la liberté religieuse
d'où la prudence du saint père il
préfère attendre que la rencontre
d'aujourd'hui tienne je cite ces riches
promesses avant d'accepter l'invitation
à moscou lancé par monsieur gorbatchev
c'est donc la fin d'une longue période
d'hostilité celle où la communauté
chrétienne affronter les tenants du
matérialisme athée
maintenant les points de vue se
rapprochent puisque les deux états vous
instaurer des relations diplomatiques
ce sont deux mondes qui vont commencer à
se parler c'est la fin des persécutions
et des excommunications sous staline
georges bortoli à rome réactions et
analyses place saint pierre des émigrés
venus de l'est comme ces ukrainiens qui
trouvent que cette visite au pape et une
bonne visite et gorbatchev un type bien
arracher at li chn et bottines cette
dame venue de tchécoslovaquie est plus
enthousiaste encore pour l gorbatchev
c'est un type formidable
c'est alexandre le grand voile a choqué
combats de chauffe nuque régner encore
qui pensent que le mouvement vers la
liberté ne s'arrêtera pas nous avons
vécu pendant soixante dix ans dans un
pays fermé
ça fait deux ans qu'il a ouvert les
frontières maintenant ce sera libre au
soir de cette visite et alors que la
première flambée d'enthousiasmé retombée
on s'aperçoit d'une chose c'est que des
deux interlocuteurs
jean paul ii et monsieur gorbatchev
c'était monsieur gorbatchev qui était le
demandeur c'est monsieur gorbatchev qui
a tenu à annoncer le premier que des
relations diplomatiques allait être en
principe et à une date non précisée
être établi entre le vatican et moscou
et c'est encore monsieur gorbatchev qui
s'est empressé d'annoncer que le pape
jean paul ii était invité en urss mais
ce soir dans un communiqué jean paul ii
se borne à répondre qu'il attendra les
développements de la situation pour
accepter cette invitation ce qui veut
dire en clair que jean paul ii attendra
d'avoir satisfaction en ce qui concerne
les uniates ukrainien qui revendiquent
leur appartenance à l'église catholique
alors que jusqu'à présent les autorités
soviétiques les rattache officiellement
à l'église orthodoxe
cory aquino a mis fin au coup d'état aux
philippines mais il a fallu l'aide des
etats-unis après une nuit et une journée
de tension à manille la présidente des
philippines madame aquino a donc déjoué
une tentative de coup d'état militaire
mais c'est l'intervention des chasseurs
des bombardiers américains dans le ciel
des philippines qui a réellement mis fin
à la rébellion
george bush le président américain n'a
pas hésité il a tout de suite et décoré
aquino à rétablir l'ordre
c'était la sixième tentative de coup
d'état contre correa queen ou martine
laroche joubert
il savait pas lu de justesse l'avion on
a des rebelles font sans pitié sur
certains points stratégiques de manille
panique parmi les troupes
gouvernementales
le palais présidentiel est bombardée par
les tirs de roquettes
le bâtiment d'une chaîne de télévision
flambent une vingtaine de morts 50
blessés pour un coup de force qui
provoque l'intervention des états unis
leurs bases militaires aux philippines
représente un sérieux enjeux
stratégiques de malte le président bush
confirme son soutien inconditionnel à la
présidente corazon aquino des avions de
combat américains survolent manie sans
participer aux combats
un effet dissuasif pour les rebelles
plus d'un millier qui finissent par se
rendre magny ce soir retrouve son calme
d'autres tentatives car la démocratie
philippines demeure fragile et les
fractures au sein de l'armée profonde
mais une fois de plus la sixième en près
de quatre ans la dame or jaune a mis sa
robe couleur chance pour annoncer la
rébellion est terminée dans la même
journée donc george bush a volé au
secours de la présidente des philippines
celle qui avait renversé marcos l'ancien
allié des américains et dans le même
temps deuxième fait michael gorbatchev
faisait lui un nouveau pas vers l'ouest
en tendant la main aux chrétiens deux
événements symboliques qui augure bien
de la rencontre des deux hommes car les
deux grands dialogue face à face des
deux ce sera au large de l'île de malte
en pleine méditerranée et pour ce
premier sommet entre gorbatchev et bush
la fièvre s'est emparée de malte marcel
trillât préparatifs des nerfs d'acier
il en aura fallu toute la journée au
président bush dont la voiture d'escort
évité de peu l'accident
peu après son arrivée à la valette à
10h30 ce matin quelques minutes plus
tard ok style en compagnie du premier
ministre de malte monsieur adami nouveau
petit frisson face à face imprévue avec
un fantôme du passé avant le sommet de
l'avenir
10h40 visite amicale au navire amiral de
la sixième flotte qui quadrillent la
méditerranée le forrestall encore un
endroit pas indiquée pour les âmes
sensibles atterrissage manqué par
bonheur lui est semée vie se tirent une
fois de plus avec les honneurs de ce
mauvais pas pourtant le pire était
encore à venir le plateau-repas de
l'homme de troupes en guise déjeuner
mais le président bush sauvé par le
ketchup ne bronche pas il en a vu
d'autres 14h50 arrivée à destination sur
le belle nappe ou le président installe
ses quartiers jusqu'à la fin de la
conférence sur les berges de la baie de
marsaxlokk le peuple maltais est venu en
voisin voir et complimenter la flotte
américaine
les petits malins qui ne manque jamais
les bonnes occasions sont là les
éternels grincheux
aussi il ferait mieux de se parler sur
la terre ferme que sur ces bateaux de
guerre mais non c'est mieux de parler de
paix sur des bateaux que de nous parler
du revient sur la terre perdre là bas
sur le belknap george bush découvre le
salon où il passera des heures en tête à
tête avec mikhaïl gorbatchev et la salle
à manger où ils dîneront ensemble demain
soir on y sera un peu à l'étroit bien
sûr et cela aidera peut-être à rompre la
glace
rarement période de l'histoire a connu
une activité diplomatique aussi intense
car dans les jours qui viennent il y
aura encore d'autres sommets d'autres
réunions à bruxelles ou à strasbourg par
exemple le monde doit trouver un nouvel
équilibre après le reflux soudain du
communisme en quelques mois
l'irruption de mikhaïl gorbatchev sur la
scène internationale a fait changer
beaucoup de choses
en quatre ans jacquat bouchard des
poignées de main échangée sous les
applaudissements des sourires accompagné
de quelques amabilités fin 85 à genève
mais sur regani gorbatchev met fin à six
années de bouderie diplomatique entre
les deux grands et il promet de se
revoir sans tarder pari tenu
un an plus tard sous le ciel de
reykjavik en islande américains et
soviétiques mettre sur la table un
projet ambitieux la destruction de
toutes les armes de portée moyenne en
europe
mais le fruit n'est pas mûr c'est
l'impasse
la déception se lit sur le visage grave
de ronald reagan au moment des adieux
les vraies retrouvailles sont pour
décembre 87 à washington avec une
amérique sous le charme du leader du
kremlin
ronald reagan et son os entre dans
l'histoire en signant le premier traité
qui prévoit une réduction effective des
arsenaux nucléaires bonne aubaine pour
le candidat bush dans la course
présidentielle au texas
il supervise sous l'oeil des caméras les
toutes premières destructions de fusée
le quatrième sommet gorbatchev rega
nommé 88 à moscou marque une certaine
apothéose les résultats sont modestes
mais certains gestes ne trompent pas
moscou n'est décidément plus la capitale
de l'empiré du mal pour le président
américain
quelques mois plus tard à l'onu michael
gorbatchev renforce son image d'homme de
paix il annonce une réduction
unilatérale des forces des tic en europe
et la maison blanche n'exclut pas une
nouvelle proposition surprise du leader
du kremlin mal même si on retire les
forces américaines et soviétiques en
fait nous les américains nous avons
toujours présent en europe par le biais
des échanges économiques
au contraire si l'armée rouge s'en va
c'en est fini de la présence soviétique
sur le vieux continent
george bush qui avait rencontré michael
gorbatchev en décembre dernier à new
york en compagnie de ronald reagan
nourri au moins une ambition avant malte
il souhaite établir une relation
personnelle de confiance avec le leader
soviétique et les changements continus
dans les démocraties populaires dernier
en date en allemagne de l'est le
mouvement d'opposition nouveau forum a
appelé à une grève générale pour le 6
décembre un moyen sans doute de vérifier
sur le terrain son impact et sa
popularité
d'autre part les députés est allemands
ont voté à l'unanimité le rôle
la suppression du rôle dirigeant du
parti communiste est-allemand les
supprimer dans la constitution et le
parlement est allemand s'est aussi
excusé auprès de la tchécoslovaquie pour
la répression du printemps de prague en
les députés ont voté une motion en ce
sens à berlin la tchécoslovaquie n'est
pas en reste aujourd'hui le parti
communiste tchécoslovaque a reconnu que
l'intervention des troupes du pacte de
varsovie en 68 était une erreur
dans le même temps on apprenait que
karel urbanek le nouveau secrétaire
général du parti communiste
tchécoslovaque se rendrait lundi à
moscou pour rencontrer mikhaïl
gorbatchev
nos envoyés spéciaux briller de l'air et
alain ont voulu savoir comment était
perçue ces changements et cette nouvelle
démocratie dans la tchécoslovaquie
profonde
reportage on est loin ici de l'allier
c'est du tumulte de prague
chez ce qu'est bodélio vite c'est petite
ville industrielle de la bohème profonde
s'éveille peu à peu au changement qui
ébranle le pays
recoupements in ear physiciens de 62 ans
représentent officiellement le forum
civique
il est l'un de ceux qui tentent depuis
longtemps déjà d'un former mais surtout
de mobiliser la province
la journée commence à la mairie première
rencontre avec les autorités
obligé de céder des locaux à
l'opposition maman sans doute étrange
pour prokop qui retrouve face à lui les
hommes qui pendant 17 ans l'an badie de
la ville le privant d'un seul coup de sa
famille et de son métier
aidés par notre présence le ton du maire
se veut cordiale mais il faudra une
heure pour que l'opposition tiennent au
moins de téléphone et une photocopieuse
un luxe pour le forum civique installés
pour l'instant dans un petit théâtre de
marionnettes
ils sont là une trentaine à travailler
jour et nuit pour coordonner l'action
des militants dans la région les moyens
sont sommaires mais on sent bien ici
comme à prague la même détermination à
ne rien céder au régime ne sont pas une
partie politique mais nous sommes une
réunion libéral de tout peuple qui veut
réformer l'état au contemporain mac pays
le gouvernement a fait beaucoup de
promesses depuis quelques jours est ce
que cela suffit à faire disparaître la
peur des mentalités pas encore je pense
la paire existe encore parmi les paysans
et c'est notre travail ici de cette
paresse et présente deux sets
pères qui ont avant encore la presse des
sources officielles la peur des
différences procopio imite doit les
combattre chaque soir sur le terrain il
choisi cette fois de nous emmener à dig
in ont accepté de se réunir une
cinquantaine de paysans du village
comptait ses camarades raconte à ce
public de mal informés méfiants les dix
jours qui ont ébranlé la thyroïde la
salle reste longtemps morose puis peu à
peu les mains se lèvent pour demander la
parole moi je suis communiste et 17
femmes et je le resterai
et nous pourrons peut-être gouverner
ensemble un dialogue timmins amorce
enfin un premier pas pour ce peuple
condamné pendant 20 ans à la peinture et
au silence
la gymnaste roumaine nadia comaneci est
en route pour new york selon le
ministère de la justice américain qu'il
a annoncé l'ancienne championne
olympique a quitté son pays mardi
dernier pour se réfugier
d'abord en hongrie dès le début on
savait que c'était aux états unis
qu'elle voulait se rendre pour fuir le
régime du dictateur ceausescu l'arménie
un an après des pages spéciales dans les
journaux de 20h présenté par daniel
bilalian demain et dimanche nous tentons
à travers nous tentons de comprendre à
travers les reportages de nos envoyés
spéciaux
comment les arméniens ont été secourues
après le terrible séisme qui les a
complètement démunis et dans la
reconstruction dans l'aide vous allez le
voir la politique n'est jamais absente
rémy roche et franck brisset
il se présente par dizaines chaque jour
dans ce petit bureau de lénine à cannes
ils ont souvent besoin de tout on a pour
principe ici de ne rien leur refuser à
priori chaque postulant fait l'objet
d'une fiche avec photos des personnes à
charge
depuis le tremblement de terre le comité
que toute une traduction la plus proche
la compassion accueille ainsi les
recalés de l'aide officielle
et ils sont nombreux parmi les 500 mille
sinistrés grâce aux dons collectés dans
toutes les usines d'arménie on donne de
la nourriture des vêtements parfois un
abri souvent de l'argent et quand il n'y
a rien dans les médias on offre une
bible et le réconfort d'un dialogue ici
il n'ya pas de bureaucratie pas de côté
officiel les gens viennent chez nous car
on parle d'égal à égal entre gens
simples et ça peut durer plusieurs
heures que toute somme travail en franc
tireur de la charité aucun contact avec
les autorités
au contraire le comité les accusent de
chercher à saboter son action il faut
dire que le président de gai tout youn
est aussi l'un des animateurs du
mouvement national arménien les
autorités de moscou ne souhaite pas la
reconstruction de l'arménie elles
veulent profiter de cette catastrophe
pour mettre à genoux le peuple arménien
et l'empêcher de poursuivre sa lutte
pour la liberté tombeau sion est d'abord
un politique mais pour lui comme pour
beaucoup des membres de son organisation
c'est la bible qui sert des ouvrages de
référence la bible qu'il ouvre au
chapitre des prophéties de saint daniel
pour envisager l'avenir des relations
entre l'arménie et l'union soviétique
ce temps l'amiral le grand prince lui
qui se tient auprès des fils de ton
peuple
ce sera un temps d'angoise elle qu'il
n'en ait pas advenu depuis qu'il existe
une nation mais c'est alors que ton
peuple se libérera coup d'arrêt au
terrorisme au pays basque 180 kilos
d'explosifs ont été découverts ce matin
à anglet c'est la plus grosse prise de
cette nature en france six personnes ont
été interpellées
parmi elles parmi elles par des rangs de
membres importants de letea and guns
girls
la cave et l'appartement clandestins
servait de base de repli aux activistes
présumés de letea militaires les
policiers en planque dans le quartier
chassaing d'anglet pensée dénicher la de
gros poissons de l'organisation
séparatiste basque
ils ont en fait mis la main sur une
cache d'armes impressionnante
près de 200 kg d'explosifs des
détonateurs des réveils 18 tubes lance
roquettes de fabrication artisanale un
arsenal découvert après plusieurs jours
dans quêtes et de filature celle de
françoise pagoaga locataire de
l'appartement mais surtout de michael
sarah b un membre présumé de thé a
soupçonné d'avoir participé à des
attentats en espagne
à l'aube les hommes des renseignements
généraux de la police judiciaire et du
raid ont interpellé à anglet mais aussi
bayonne et bidart si basque français et
espagnol
un coup de filet dont les policiers
espèrent se servir pour déstabiliser le
mouvement terroriste basque eta qui se
manifestait encore il ya un mois en
abattant un général de l'armée espagnole
à madrid
d'autres informations internationales et
françaises aussi de ce vendredi avec me
caruso d'abord un attentat à bruxelles
cette fois dans une faculté
explosion criminelle ce matin dans
l'université libre de bruxelles quatre
personnes blessées dont une grièvement
l'attentât n'a pas été revendiqué mais
un suspect a été appréhendé peu après
l'homme aurait été vu sur les lieux
juste avant l'explosion
le 6 décembre 88 une bombe avait été
découverte dans la même université
istvan adpa trappe singh leader du parti
du peuple a été nommé aujourd'hui pour
former le nouveau gouvernement indien
l'ancien ministre des finances de rajiv
gandhi vive s'attaquerait la corruption
mais aussi aux problèmes du népal et de
sri lanka monsieur signe dirigera le
premier gouvernement minoritaire de
l'inde depuis l'indépendance
vingt-quatre heures après l'assassinât
du président de la deutsche bank la
police ouest allemande est identifié
l'un des suspects d'après un portrait
robot
il s'agirait de christoph zeitler 31 ans
sade et terroriste de la fraction armée
rouge les plus recherchés
manifestation ce soir à paris à l'appel
du parti communiste et du mrap pour
protester contre l'extrême droite
ce rassemblement intervenait deux jours
avant le second tour des législatives
partielles de dreux et marseille où les
candidats du front national ont créé la
surprise
françois mitterrand à dunkerque pour le
3ème colloque sur l'accessibilité des
transports aux handicapés le président
de la république s'est déclaré contre
l'exclusion partout et sous toutes ses
formes
il a également annoncé le lancement
d'une véritable politique européenne
pour les handicapés
la bourse de paris elle reste insensible
aux frimas de l'hiver la séance s'est de
nouveau achevée sur une hausse +1 55%
une résistance qui fait défaut au dollar
à 6 francs 08 70 et une fois de plus le
ciel risque de nous tomber sur la tête
la nuit prochaine c'était la crainte de
nos grands-pères les gaulois avec les
satellites que nous en voyons souvent on
peut commencer à s'inquiéter solarmax
retombera en effet cette nuit la nasa
vient de l'annoncer et seules armes at
pèse trois tonnes
reste à prier que le satellite se
désintègre avant de toucher terre
philippe dumez cela max un satellite de
trois tonnes était déjà en panne peu
après son lancement 81 me en 84 il avait
été réparée dans l'espace par l'équipage
du dixième vol d'une navette spatiale
américaine
au cours d'une sortie très spectaculaire
les astronautes avaient réussi à
attraper le satellite et à le placer
dans la soute pour effectuer les
réparations
c'était une première spatiale après
avoir étudié de très belles éruption
solaire solar mac est arrivé à
l'épuisement de ses réserves de
carburant et il va donc retombé sur
terre dans quelques heures
les spécialistes estiment qu'il va se
désintégrer mais les morceaux pèseront
100 ou 200 kg le point d'impact se
situera près de l'équateur une région
qui ne comporte que 20% de terre cela
pouvait être au sud de la floride non
loin de son lieu de lancement tennis à
grand spectacle samedi et dimanche soir
sur antenne 2 demi-finales et finales
des masters avec les quatre meilleurs
joueurs du monde qui se sont qualifiés
après becker edberg la nuit dernière
c'est d'abord lendl comme prévu qui n'a
pas traîné pour se propulser en demi
finale il a éliminé l'américain chris
stein et puis l'idole de new york john
mcenroe son corps lendl john mcenroe le
voici s'est qualifié lui aussi il a
disputé pendant plus de trois heures un
match pour venir à bout au madison
square garden de new york a elle chante
le vainqueur de roland-garros ambiance
électrique coup magique pour big mac à
l'arrivée 6 2 5 7 6 4
ma
hydro est qualifié donc rendez vous
demain 22h45 pour la première des
demi-finales des masters
une aventure de notre siècle toujours
plus loin toujours plus dur c'est la
transe antartica du docteur jean louis
etienne il s'agit bien sûr de traverser
l'antarctique dans le froid la neige et
la glace en passant par le pôle sud
l'expédition qui rassemble des
représentants de six pays est parti
depuis plusieurs mois elles rencontrent
beaucoup de difficultés mais elles
progressent
pierre lepetit gens ma mère exploit ils
sont six partis maintenant depuis plus
de trois mois cohabiter dans le froid la
neige et le vent un japonais un russe un
chinois un français un américain et un
anglais tous attirés vers le même but
sortira mirny au delà du pôle sud mais
chacun avec une mission différente
le chinois chindaï est un glaciologue
dès qu'ils le peuvent ils effectuent des
prélèvements et relevés glaciaire il
cherche à mieux connaître cet article où
il a pourtant déjà hiverner à deux
reprises le russe victor boyard ski
amateurs de bains neige étudie lui
l'atmosphère et en particulier la couche
d'ozone
et puis jean louis etienne le français
le docteur son étude et celle du corps
humain et de ses cellules de son
adaptation au froid et à la consommation
massive d'aliments gras dans des
conditions extrêmes il est aussi un peu
le psychologue du groupe ya jamais eu de
friction entre nous
les décisions ont été prises de manière
générale à l'unanimité les décisions
qu'on a eu à prendre c est ce qu on y va
ou est-ce qu'on n'y va pas
quand le temps est extrêmement mauvais
mais soit si will soit stieger soit
c'est moi qui qui de temps en temps sur
thomas le blizzard pour dire bon c'est
pas trop trop mauvais on peut y aller on
n'a jamais eu de sources de de conflit
entre nous
et heureusement car leur longue route
n'est pas encore finie étape par étape
il s'approche du pôle sud qu'ils
espèrent atteindre aux environs du 12
décembre
ce ne sera pourtant que la première
partie de l'expédition un aussi long
chemin les attend pour atteindre mirny
en union soviétique
le point final de cette grande aventure
vite vite les pronos du tiers cqeer est
bresse propose de jouer demain pour ce
tiercé à saint cloud le 11 le 13 le 5 le
8 le 6 las le 12 et le spectre de la
météo s'est tout de suite avec sophie
davant dernière édition henri sannier
vers 23 heures juste après apostrophe
présenté par bernard pivot
demain bernard pivot vous donne rendez
vous au 6 à 13h20 sur antenne 2 pour la
dictée de la finale du championnat
international d'orthographe ce sera à la
bibliothèque nationale entre la dictée
elle corrigé les participants seront les
premiers à découvrir les 100 trésors de
la bibliothèque nationale on va voir des
images espère c'est très joli
une grande exposition pour les fêtes de
fin d'année alors on me dit y a pas
d'image c'est dommage donc rendez-vous
13h20 demain la bibliothèque nationale
avec bernard pivot ce week end
bilalian avec betty dureau et philippe
gassot pour les joueurs